that coming up at the end of the third  quarter  just a little over two minutes to go in  the period and jimmy butler shoots over  trey  rebound hunter  miami's dropped off to 46 overall trey  at mid floor butler on him  and jimmy  going for that steal comes up with it  trey ties him up  good hustle by trae young taking out  jimmy butler  go ahead and flex on them trying to tell  me what i'm not to be played with  jimmy butler of course one of the very  best defenders in the nba  a four-time all-nba  a five-time ball defensive team member  he went after that ball but trey never  gave up i like the hustle by trade  standing in there fighting  and that's what you want to see talk  about a sense of urgency trey young you  want that from your best player showing  that hey you know what i'm going for it  all oh and then butler gets